Rex Tillerson is the kind of guy Donald
Trump loves he's a business leader an
international deal maker and he leads a
global operation a lifetime oil
executive the 64 year old Tillerson has
spent the last four decades of Exxon he
also has no experience working in the
public sector just like a number of
people who have been nominated to
Trump's cabinet this is Rex Tillerson
path to one of the most powerful
positions in America Rex Tillerson was
born in Wichita Falls Texas in 1954 he
became an Eagle Scout at 13 and
graduated from the University of Texas
at Austin in 1976 where he earned a
degree in civil engineering he also
played the drums in the Longhorns
marching band after college Tillerson
joined Exxon Mobil as an engineer where
he then worked his way up through the
ranks to become CEO in 2006 Exxon has
grown a great deal under his leadership
with operations on six of seven
continents and a market value of more
than 350 billion dollars and that's what
Donald Trump values above all else
his deal-making qualities so this is
something that looks from emphasized in
his own campaign you know he's a deal
maker he's a guy who gets things done
he's not just a bureaucrat that's Nick
bottoms the foreign policy reporter of
Bloomberg those deals the Tillerson
makes are at the highest level he also
does know a lot of foreign leaders he's
been all over the world he's he's met a
lot of these people and Russia Tillison
ties to Russian President Vladimir Putin
go back almost two decades piece of
personal friend of Russian President
Vladimir Putin he got the order of
French
from Russia in 2013 since the 90s
ExxonMobil brokered two massive deals
with the Russian government to explore
for oil but when Russia annexed Crimea
in 2014
the u.s. responded with sanctions
against Russia that froze Exxon's Arctic
agreement one of the things we do know
how to quickly about rec sources track
record is that he does not favor
sanctions he believes that they're very
difficult to enforce properly and that
generally they should not be used if
those sanctions on Russia were lifted
exxon would likely stance to prompt this
is a big deal and one of the questions
we're really looking at is how much
Tillerson will be acting in the
interests of the united states versus
the interests of the energy sector and
whether he'll be able to differentiate
between the tube and because of that
conflict of interest Tillerson stepped
down from his CEO position at Exxon in
January and sold off his 600,000 shares
in the company then there's the question
of climate change where Tillerson is
credited for changing Exxon's position
to recognize the reality of global warm
coercion has said repeatedly that he
does believe the carbon emissions
however he does think this is something
that's manageable and can be controlled
how are we gonna make the world's energy
needs in the future and do it in a way
that is environmentally responsible and
manages this risk of climate change
however some of his critics say that
while Exxon acknowledges the dangers of
climate change they fund advocacy groups
who underplay it so if one of the most
important roles and trumps to
administration it all comes down to who
influences to us and most his boss his
company himself
[Music]